we were totally unprepared for how bad
it was we weren't sure about what was
gonna happen
raised hand which I gained through a
graveyard graveyard of mangroves
[Music]
Nigeria's oil reserves have made it the
biggest economy in Africa you have huge
oil companies that are making billions
and billions of dollars and it's not
faltering down to the poor and they are
really really disillusioned they are
angry I love Nigeria my sister was born
there my parents met and married there I
spent my early childhood there so I love
Nigeria the Niger Delta is on the coast
it's a vast area that is inter woven by
a latticework of waterways it is rich
rich in these natural resources in
particular the black gold foiling and
yet the people are pitifully four plus
there's incredibly high degree of
corruption there's a lot of animosity in
the region because of all the wealth
that is generated there and so little of
it is pumped back into the area I wanted
to show how oil thieves were basically
running that part of Nigeria the idea
was to try and get access to these
people so they could show us what they
were doing
we were totally unprepared for how bad
it was
it was shocking beyond shocking
oyel thieving is an industry there and
along with the oil thieving there is
kidnapping and ransom and stealing it is
a racket beyond rackets everyone is in
on it it's unbelievable to think that
but that is a reality of the data and
that's how they operate that's crazy but
if you experience it's almost like the
wild wasting you go in knowing that
there's a history of kidnapping and
you're the wrong color so you stand out
as a prime kidnap victim going in
quickly and quietly and getting out
quickly and quietly is this the most
effective way but we also had to take a
security escort with us as well this is
a difficult area because I have been
kidnapping so we've got people guarding
us in the front vehicle we're gonna be
in the middle and then we've got a rear
vehicle as well it took a long time to
get to the right kingpin because there
are lots of smaller thieves who wanted
to get in on the act and we'd spend all
this time chasing shadows and not
getting to the right person just by
chance someone who was staying in the
place where we were staying happened to
know a person and he said our introduces
someone he is the real deal
turns out demon was extremely powerful
extremely successful and boy did he know
how to get round that whole system
he had an escort and he came in a police
car that was the level of protection
I took one look at him and I thought oh
my gosh he cannot be in charge of
anything he was about mid-twenties
didn't look like anything I thought how
can he be running an oil racket you
would have never ever thought that this
was one of the most powerful people in
the area we weren't sure about what was
going to happen and where we were going
to go pretty busy place the jetty can
see what you need a bit of protection
because really stand out here if you're
not from this area he took us on the
boat and he said if the Navy comes along
just try and keep down
within that area you've also got the
military flying around on boats looking
for militia looking for oil thieves and
they don't want you around a police Navy
guard spotted us as was ipping along and
obviously there was no hiding they
shouted at us to put our arms up to
everyone put their arms up praise and
all and we were thinking for this is it
we're gonna be turned back but it's not
going well I kind of kept recording
obviously I didn't want to make it
obvious I kept the camera down you could
see our hands up in the air everyone was
nervous though kind of like everyone was
up where they hand thinking what's gonna
happen here
and the Navy guard said have you been
kidnapped to us we said no no no we
haven't been kidnapped and I said we've
got permission to be here they wanted to
steal the fuel that we had on board so
mo had to pull the diesel into their
boat
[Music]
an emu then took over the boat and
piloted it suddenly he went from this
shy subservient quiet man with the navy
guard to this moon just powered the boat
and expertly he was taking us into his
territory so once he got past the Navy
guard he was perfectly confident that he
would be all right in broad daylight
with his huge
billowing clouds of putrid smoke they
were burning oil to extract and refine
the oil it looks like it should have
been pretty because there was all these
mangroves all round and you're going
round weaving your way through this very
tight little waterway
it looked apocalyptic oil stained
mangrove swamps where you could see the
oil line from where the oil had stained
the roots of the trees
It was as if we were on a different
planet everything was black the
mangroves were dead the roots were were
in black water and then we came across
these huge Dodgers with I would imagine
millions and millions of litres of crude
oil what must be a multi-million pound
industry
thank you the barges were enormous so
that you could have a long walk on them
and they were all full of oil and he had
seven of them
in that small area like this they siphon
it off from the oil companies and Lehman
told me that is with some sort of
cooperation from parts of the oil
companies we're doing because we had no
jobs no jobs understand he was
incredibly articulate he knew that there
was a problem what major airports we are
doing it illigal we want governmental
assisted I would you eat a leg up but he
was employing thousands of men to
extract the oil and to process the oil
soon as you got off the boat you slipped
oh yeah oops blimey he was straight into
oil every rainwater there was a slick of
oil over everything look at the state of
this water what was obviously
devastatingly beautiful area thick now
with crude oil and it goes on for miles
it was like oil oil oil everywhere
a lot of the pollution comes from
attempts to siphon off their oil
pipelines are broken and that oil gets
spread throughout the environment so a
lot of the damage does come from local
people trying to make money out of the
oil
he was a modern-day Robin Hood figure
and that is definitely how he saw
himself he felt he was giving
opportunities to these people who
wouldn't have employment who wouldn't be
able to feed their families they looked
up to him mm-hmm
and he was showing us his operation like
he would take someone round you're embar
this is he looks no different to anyone
else that was working those processing
plants but you realize when you chat him
that he was quite special he saw himself
as an oil entrepreneur and there's an
integral part of the economy big
companies are making money so we do a
walk so I have something nice what
adversity thank you
thank you I knew he was using us and
that was okay because he wanted a
message and I wanted to see his
operation it gave us access to something
that was pretty inaccessible that's what
he wanted to come in from the cold
we had to be very quick because he was
conscious there was a military operation
going on where they were trying to bomb
the refineries
I wasn't given much time they didn't
want us they for lunch my radar was
going nuts
saying this is not right be careful the
danger signals going off all the time
but once you're in it there's no turning
back
you know missionaries got to take them
and one got shot whilst he was singing
Amazing Grace not even sure I could do
the first line of Amazing Grace all the
time you're there you're thinking I
wonder how many times he's thinking we
could take them hostage hi there honey
we went out fishing with one community
where they've lived there for decades
just very simple lives with no running
water no proper roads no electricity and
they've lived quite well up until now
because of the water because they can
fish and they can eat and they can make
a living on it not anymore
well that's quite a lot of damage they
can't survive on fishing largely which
what they would have done water is
contaminated that the people drink
obviously the dew point everybody form
you've got many teeth do this form it's
a horrendously bleak picture it's the
saddest thing I have ever ever seen that
a whole ecosystem can be so destroyed
like it was gosh anything nothing
anymore I came through a graveyard the
graveyard of mangroves
the water had this rainbow sheen of it
where the oil floated on the surface the
oil has killed everything they're still
fishing quite remarkably in this oil
slick they were just saying we hardly
catch any fish there's no fish but still
they were fishing oh yeah our body
body they're dragging myths but there's
like two tiny fish in it and can't
imagine what those fish tastes like no
matter where you went you could smell
this dust real small oh these smell this
smell of pollution and it was so
incredibly sad to see the destruction
the damage in some areas is almost total
you can see that it would be the most
incredibly beautiful place if it weren't
for the oil which covers everything
it's almost monochromatic there are
communities which have been devastated
we definitely blame the oil companies
and feel that they have basically raped
Nigeria of its natural resources and
unfortunately that is storing up a whole
load of resentment in these communities
about these rich greedy companies who
are owned by Britain America and
therefore a scene as British or American
remarkably the oil thieves in these
communities are not seen in such a
negative light they're people who are
from their community who are trying to
scrape a living but they're not painted
in the same way that the big
multinational oil companies that rule
world are they are polluting the waters
with their activities and they are
siphoning off oil that should normally
go to the government but they have no
jobs they've got no food to eat how else
are they going to survive
it's a constant battle of the small man
against the Goliath of an oil company
and the victims and the communities that
are in their way are being treated as
pretty much dispensable the conflict
with those that have been don't have
it's going to continue EMU wanted us to
deliver his message and he saw we might
be able to do that and you know he was
quite charming he even drove us to the
airport
afterwards I mean not our security
guards went nuts so I got into his car
and the security guy was going oh my god
oh my god what are you doing we can't
look after you if you're getting into
his car don't worry
he says he's taking us to the airport
and by that stage I was pretty convinced
that he was going to stick to his word
and sure enough he delivered us to
terminal 1
you
[Music]